και ατικούμαστε γιατί δεν έχουμε την ποσότητα και που πρέπει δεν έχουμε την τεχνιολογία και
που πρέπει δεν είχαμε τη στήρηξη κεί που πρέπει αλλά το πιο σημαντικό την αξιοκρατεία
όοη αυτές τις δεγαϊτίες και αυτό μας δημειορούσε εντρομερά προβλήματα στην ανέλιξη κάποιο δεν τους
βαζουμε όλους το διογαλάφη σίγουρα υπήρχα και εξερέσεις του καλούν από άξιζε να προακθούν αλλά
ναι έχετε δίκαιο λόγο τις πιότι τα στων αστυνομικό που είαι πολύψηλοι οι κυπρικ αστνομική
δεν είναι το ανάλογον αποτέλεσμα παρόλο που υπερβάλλονε αυτό του νομί ζωωσής βλέπετε από μόνο
σασταδελτεία τι πουπβγαίνουνμες ελίψεις και εξεχνιάζεις και των αντιτο μεετέτρεψαν κάποιοι δην αστυνομία σε ένα
πανεπιστιμίο δηλαδή αν έχει στα πτυχία προφωράς αν είσα τις πρώτης γραμμής και δεν έχει
στοσες πολλές ορές να δουλέψεις μένι στάσημος μετέτρεψαν την αστυνομία και θα το πω σε
σε έναν ίδος γράφει οκρατίας γραφειοκρατικής ανέληξες έχεις πτυχείο προάγεσαι δουλεύεις δεν προαγές αυτόν το
έκαναν σκόπιμα όταν το έκανα γιατί το πτυχείο δεν πρεπε να έχει δι θμιστικού ρόλος
στην προαγωλγή πρέπει να είναι απλά ένα σημείο ν επιπρόσθετο όχι όμως όρε θμιστικός ρόλος
που έχει σήμερα και αυτόν πρέπει να αλλάξει γιατί αυτή τη στιγμή έχουμε ανθρώπους που
δουλεύουν στην πρώτηγραμμή δεν έχου πτυχία φέίρνουν ις πέρας πάμπολλες υποθέσεις ρισκάνον τις ζωές τους
επιχειρήσεις κα έχω ανθρώπους οι οποία προακθηκαν οι οποίοι ποτέ δεν έχουν πάρει μια ανανάκρηση
οι οποίοι ποτέ δεν έχουν κάνει μιαν παρακολούθηση οι οποίοι ποτέ δε έχουν ετηθεί ένανήταλπανέρευνας
από το δικαστήριο ολά αυτά οι αστυνομική δου για πτέμον τις πρώτης γραμμς τα υπόλιπα
δεναι ένα αστυνομική τουγια θρό νας δεν ημερός ο κύριθυσίαμου τριάντά τις εκατό μέσων όρο
των αστυνομιών του εξωτερικού τα μέλη τους δεν είναι αστυνομική είναι αυτοί πολίτες που εργάζονται
στην αστυνομία και να κάννουν δουκές που πρέπει μες